Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sama Sambuddhassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sama Sambuddhassa
Hommage au Bouddha, le noble bienheureux et celui qui attend la veille pleinement.
Je n'ai pas attendu tant de questions, donc je vais faire les questions d'abord, et puis peut-être qu'il y aura du temps.
Donc je ne m'attendais pas à autant de questions, donc je vais d'abord parler des questions, et puis on verra après s'il reste du temps pour l'enseignement.
Donc la première question est, comment expliquerais-tu l'intensité du Bouddha en termes de Bouddha ?
Donc la première question c'est comment est-ce que vous expliqueriez un ennui intense et profond en termes bouddhistes ?
Donc des fois je fais l'expérience de l'ennui dans la méditation marché et comment est-ce que je peux la décomposer et puis travailler avec ?
Donc
Comme je disais hier, il y a certaines conséquences liées à la complaisance et puis à l'attachement.
Donc, pendant qu'on est en train de profiter de quelque chose, on dit simplement qu'on pense que c'est le nirvana.
Donc, quand on regarde un film, on est dans un état de plaisir total.
Et donc la mesure de ce plaisir est que nous nous perdons complètement dedans.
Et quand le film finit, alors voilà, je suis de nouveau là.
Où est-ce que j'étais pendant ces deux heures ?
Mais malheureusement, ça a produit une certaine relation avec les films, avec les DVDs.
Mais malheureusement, en fait, ça crée une relation particulière avec les films, avec les DVD.
Donc, souvenez-vous, quand on ne peut pas voir, on se sent frustré.
Non, si vous ne pouvez pas en voir quand vous voulez en voir.
Quand vous ne pouvez pas voir de film.
Donc à ce moment-là, vous vous sentez frustré.
Si vous allez chercher un DVD et puis il s'avère que ce n'est pas ce que vous vous attendiez, alors vous êtes fâché, vous êtes déçu.
Donc si vous avez un DVD que vous aimez beaucoup et puis que vous le perdez, vous serez triste.
Donc votre relation avec les DVD, ça croît et puis ça devient une forme de dépendance.
Une sorte de comportement compulsif.
Maintenant, s'il n'y a plus de DVD, il y a aussi la peur et l'anxiété qu'il n'y aura plus de DVD.
Et puis, un jour, vous vous trouvez dans un lieu où il n'y a pas de DVD.
Donc, il y a ces longues périodes de temps qui, avant, vous pouviez juste vous perdre dans les DVDs.
Alors qu'avant, c'était des moments où vous pouviez vous perdre dans ces DVD.
Alors que maintenant, il n'y a plus rien.
Et là, c'est l'envie.
Le boredom.
Il y a aussi un boredom qui arrive si vous avez à regarder le même DVD tout le temps.
ça peut devenir une souffrance le boredom est la mesure de votre attachement et votre recherche de la bonheur dans quelque chose
c'est la mesure donc la mesure de la quantité de votre ennui donc cette recherche du bonheur le résultat sera l'ennui non, la mesure la mesure de votre attachement la mesure de combien vous dépendez des DVD pour votre bonheur
Donc la mesure de combien vous dépendez du DVD pour votre bonheur équivaut à la quantité de souffrance que vous ressentez quand le DVD n'est pas là.
Donc si quelqu'un vit une vie vraiment très plaisante et excitante, ils ont assez d'argent pour aller où ils veulent.
Ils vont au théâtre, à l'opéra, n'importe où.
Et puis ils invitent des amis, ils vont souper dehors.
Donc soudainement,
Une grande maladie arrive et ils sont coincés à la maison.
Ou encore pire, ils souffrent de cette crise financière.
Qu'est-ce qui est pire, une maladie physique ou une crise financière ?
Ensuite, vous voyez, ils ont un gros problème parce que qu'est-ce qu'ils font ?
C'est là qu'ils s'aperçoivent qu'il y a un gros problème, parce que qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire ?
Parce que le bonheur dépend de la quantité d'excitation qu'ils peuvent produire, qu'ils peuvent avoir.
Donc, quand la cause de la bonheur disparaît, ils sont laissés avec cette énorme épuisement, ressentiment, boredom.
quand la cause de leur bonheur disparaît alors ils sont laissés à eux-mêmes avec ce sentiment d'ennui donc je me considère toujours comme étant très chanceux parce que quand j'étais enfant j'ai appris à jouer au piano et j'étais en pratique et mon père était là
Donc je pratiquais et mon père était là.
Et je me suis tourné vers lui et j'ai dit, mais c'est vraiment ennuyeux.
Et il a dit, ne t'inquiète pas mon fils, continue de jouer et regarde ce qui se passe.
Donc j'ai continué de jouer et soudain, j'ai pu jouer la tune.
Oh !
donc j'ai continué de jouer et puis tout à coup j'ai pu jouer la mélodie donc j'ai appris vraiment très jeune que la réponse pour vaincre l'ennui c'est la répétition donc vous faites la méditation marchée
Personnellement, je ne peux pas penser à quelque chose de plus ennuyant que la méditation marchée.
Donc, il y a cette expectation que nous faisons quelque chose qui va lever un certain intérêt excitant.
Donc il y a cette attente que cela va éveiller en nous cet intérêt d'excitation.
Et on est là à répéter la même chose encore et encore.
Les mêmes mots, lever, avancer, poser.
Et donc maintenant, une fois que cette bordure arrive, notre attention s'éloigne de la bordure.
Une fois que l'ennui apparaît, alors notre attention va vers l'ennui.
Parce qu'on s'identifie tellement vite à nos émotions.
Donc l'ennui, on dit je m'ennuie.
Quand vous êtes devenu l'ennui, il n'y a pas d'escapement.
Et une fois que vous êtes devenu l'ennui, il n'y a plus d'échappatoire.
Donc c'est cela que fait l'identité, c'est qu'elle vous enferme là-dedans.
Donc, dès que vous la reconnaissez, vous tournez vers elle.
La reconnaissez.
C'est la même chose.
Si je reconnais quelqu'un, je dis « Ah !
»
et puis quand je l'accueille, je dis, oh je crois que c'est le même verbe en français c'est d'être le même verbe donc immédiatement je me désidentifie je suis maintenant l'observateur de l'ennui c'est toujours pas plaisant
mais c'est toujours désagréable
mais au moins là je suis libéré de ces attentes parce que cet ennui est en train de me dire d'aller faire quelque chose de plus excitant alors que maintenant je dis stop je note ennui et puis j'enlève j'enlève pour qu'il revienne complètement ou j'y entre pour ressentir son constituant
Donc là, je lui permets de se manifester complètement et puis d'y pénétrer pour ressentir sa texture.
Donc je deviens vraiment très intime avec le ressenti de l'ennemi.
je perds cette aversion envers l'ennui.
Peut-être même que je perds que la peur envers l'ennui disparaît.
Souvenez-vous que l'ennui est très proche d'un manque de sens.
Le manque de sens est très proche du désespoir.
Si par exemple, votre vie, nous savons, n'est-ce pas, qu'il y a des exemples, des gens qui ont une carrière ou qui ont construit un business ?
Par exemple, nous savons bien que des personnes qui ont une carrière ou qui montent un business, pour une raison ou une autre, l'entreprise disparaît et puis la personne perd son job.
Donc là arrive ce manque de sens par rapport à sa vie.
Et c'est une des raisons souvent pour le suicide.
ça peut être souvent une raison qui peut conduire au suicide donc l'ennui est vraiment à considérer comme un état mental non bénéfique
Mais donc si vous arrivez à rester avec l'ennui, à vraiment la ressentir, alors à ce moment-là vous lui permettez de s'épuiser, cette énergie de s'épuiser.
Et donc souvenez-vous que ces états négatifs vont toujours aller vers leur opposé.
Rien n'est perdu.
Mais tout est transformé.
Donc au fur et à mesure que l'ennui disparaît, un intérêt naturel va émerger.
C'est ce que nous faisons.
C'est la même instruction tout le temps.
Avec tous ces états négatifs.
Il y a un moment de désidentification.
Donc il y a un moment de désidentification.
Donc pas je suis, je m'ennuie, mais il y a ennui.
Là.
Donc vraiment aller à l'intérieur de l'ennui et puis lui laisser se manifester.
Et savoir que cette manifestation est cette énergie
donc de savoir que cette énergie qui se manifeste elle se transforme mais en même temps elle est brûlée elle se consume donc de manière générale pour la vie de tous les jours
Donc essayez de trouver des moments dans la journée où vous pouvez développer la tranquillité.
Donc un goût pour le neutre.
Un goût pour la paix, la tranquillité, le calme.
et cela va nous conduire dans la bonne direction mais donc de manière évidente on peut devenir aussi attaché au silence mais au fur et à mesure que l'attachement diminue ça c'est le meilleur à garder
Est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer le non-moi, le non-je, et puis donner un exemple au niveau physique ?
Le Bouddha, dans le second discours qu'il donne,
donc dans le deuxième discours qu'a donné le Bouddha à ses compagnons précédents il leur a simplement posé trois questions et ces trois questions viennent d'une définition de ce qu'est un esprit ou une âme
donc ces trois questions viennent de la définition de ce qu'elle soit ou l'âme donc celles-là étaient les définitions principales en ce temps-là donc la première chose c'est que elle cela n'a pas changé
Donc il avait complètement contrôle sur soi, de son âme.
Donc l'âme était toujours dans un état de bonheur.
Donc voilà les trois définitions de l'âme tant qu'elle ne change pas elle est toujours en contrôle et pour cette raison elle est toujours heureuse
Donc si vous êtes toujours en contrôle, il n'y a pas de raison de vous rendre malheureux.
Donc regardez, observez le corps, observez vos émotions, observez votre esprit et puis posez-vous ces trois questions.
Est-ce que ça change ou non ?
Est-ce que ça change ou pas ?
Donc si cela change, alors ça ne peut pas être le soi, ça ne peut pas être moi.
Donc ressentez vos émotions.
Est-ce qu'elles changent ?
Donc si elles changent, elles ne peuvent pas être moi, elles ne peuvent pas être à moi.
Et en soi, elles ne peuvent pas être en soi.
Elle-même, itself, the self.
No, no, no, no.
The emotion itself can't be a self.
Les émotions elles-mêmes ne peuvent pas être le soi.
Thoughts, do they change?
Les pensées, est-ce qu'elles changent?
If they change, then they can't be a self.
Donc si elles changent, elles ne peuvent pas être un soi.
Non.
Donc maintenant, est-ce que vous êtes en contrôle parfait de votre corps, de vos émotions et de vos pensées ?
Donc un des compagnons a dit non, Bhagavan.
Il dit, si vous n'êtes pas en contrôle, comment peut-il être vous ?
Donc alors si tu n'es pas en contrôle, comment est-ce que ça peut être toi ?
Comment est-ce que ça peut être un soi ?
Donc maintenant, si ça change et tu es en contrôle, est-ce que c'est ça ?
Est-ce que c'est ça la souffrance ?
Ou est-ce que c'est satisfaisant ?
Non, Baba.
Oui.
Donc, quand il s'agit de la douleur physique, je suis assis ici et mon nez commence à blesser.
Donc, quand il s'agit des douleurs physiques, je suis assis là et puis mon genou commence à devenir douloureux.
Non, je ne lui ai pas demandé.
Et je ne peux pas lui dire maintenant, attends.
Donc, cela n'est pas à moi, n'est pas à moi.
Donc le plus vous allez pouvoir rentrer à l'intérieur du ressenti de la douleur, vous allez peu à peu perdre cette définition de douleur.
Vous allez dire soit chaleur ou bien sensation d'être à l'étroit.
Vous voyez ?
Donc c'est de cette façon qu'on utilise les enseignements sur ce n'est pas moi, ce n'est pas à moi.
Donc la même chose avec les émotions.
Donc si une irritation émerge parce que quelqu'un a toussé ou...
ou il se peut que je sois devenu attaché au silence mais la colère est apparue et je ne lui ai pas demandé de venir et à partir du moment où je la remarque je note colère, colère si je ne l'identifie pas
Donc si je m'identifie à elle, est-ce que je te parle ?
Donc je réagis.
Je deviens la colère.
Donc en pratiquant cela, nous reprenons le contrôle de notre vie.
Donc en pratiquant de cette manière, nous reprenons possession de notre vie.
Plutôt que d'être toujours conduit par le désir, par des vieilles émotions.
C'est pour ça que cette attention claire, nous devons toujours l'avoir avec nous.
Et elle saisit le premier mouvement.
Donc si par exemple vous parlez avec quelqu'un et puis vous avez cette attention globale ou un peu d'attention sur vous.
là vous pouvez sentir le début d'une irritation et le simple fait de le savoir va faire qu'elle ne va pas s'accroître mais si vous ne la reconnaissez pas elle va vous monter le vent du dos comme un serpent dans l'herbe et donc dans le pire des cas vous pouvez être dans une rage computer rage
Si vous êtes en rage contre votre ordinateur.
vous êtes en train de travailler votre ordinateur et puis vous sentez que ça commence à monter parce que ça ne marche pas comme vous voulez et quelque chose tout à coup vraiment se plante alors là ça...
donc tout l'enseignement sur le non-soi devient un exercice intellectuel il y a tellement de livres maintenant sur la signification du non-soi et ça devient une philosophie
donc un des grands philosophes bouddhistes c'est Nagarjuna
Donc il est vraiment reconnu comme un philosophe.
Tandis que le Bouddha est plutôt reconnu comme un psychologue.
Il n'y a pas vraiment de discours philosophiques.
Donc même si la philosophie est inclue dans les enseignements du Douda, il ne s'éternise pas sur la philosophie.
Et donc ça on peut le voir parce que dans les derniers enseignements, l'Abhidhamma, c'est vraiment une psychologie éthique.
c'est seulement dans le bouddhisme, les bouddhistes plus récents, plus modernes, qu'on trouve ces traces philosophiques.
Et les érudits occidentaux adorent ça.
Et dans un sens, ils le font tout extraordinairement compliqué.
et d'une certaine manière ils arrivent à rendre ça vraiment très compliqué mais si vous lisez les écritures et vous voyez comment le Bouddha l'utilise vous voyez que c'est juste un outil d'enseignement ok quand nous
Quand on a vraiment une réalisation profonde par rapport à nos émotions ou nos sentiments, qu'est-ce qui se passe ensuite ?
Est-ce qu'il faut juste attendre jusqu'à ce qu'elles disparaissent ?
Donc ça fait partie de ce non-soi.
Donc ces émotions ont leur propre énergie, leur propre force de vie.
Oui, vous ne pouvez pas...
Je ne sais pas d'une façon facile de relancer ces émotions éclatées dans notre système.
Donc, je ne connais pas de manière facile pour pouvoir libérer ces sentiments... Donc, ces sentiments qui sont vraiment emprisonnés.
Donc, il peut y avoir des techniques psychothérapeutiques.
Donc, ce qu'il faut comprendre, c'est si vous prenez une émotion...
par exemple la colère ce qu'il y a dans le système c'est un gros ballon de feu ce feu n'appartient à rien et donc ce qui se passe c'est que quand quelque chose nous irrite c'est comme un petit pinprick dans le ballon
Et donc ce qui se passe, c'est quand quelque chose nous irrite, c'est comme une petite pique dans ce ballon.
Et donc toute la colère va essayer de sortir par ce petit trou.
C'est de cette manière qu'on finit avec à donner des réponses qui sont vraiment déplacées.
Donc, ce n'est pas que c'est une autre personne ou quelque chose qui est la cause de ma colère.
Non, c'est juste le déclencheur.
Donc, je crée l'angoisse à l'intérieur de moi.
donc je crée la colère à l'intérieur de moi-même et donc la colère n'est pas spécifique c'est une attitude si l'on a un profond insight dans les sentiments c'est le processus de libérer soi-même de leur pouvoir sur toi
Donc si on a vraiment une grande réalisation par rapport à un ressenti, et bien c'est ce processus de... Donc c'est le processus de libérer
ce pouvoir que cela a sur nous le ressenti ok il me semble qu'il y a un monde entre intention et action entre l'intention et l'action quand j'ai besoin de prendre une décision
Donc je dois prendre une décision.
Donc j'hésite entre plusieurs choix.
Donc je m'assieds et je ressens.
Et parfois je peux ressentir une intention ou deux.
Mais il n'y a pas de chemin qui amène vers l'action.
Est-ce que je suis simplement paresseuse ?
Et puis, est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer ce qu'est la paresse ?
La différence avec l'acceptation.
Quand il s'agit, dans la psychologie bouddhiste, une intention n'est pas une action.
donc en termes de psychologie bouddhiste une intention ça n'est pas une action ça reste encore au stade de potentiel c'est juste une idée qui a été aromatisée avec le désir par le désir donc par exemple je peux être assis dans ma chambre et puis je regarde le paysage
Et tout à coup, le thé.
Donc le désir, il vient avec le désir.
Mais tout en, enfin...
en sachant que j'ai déjà eu trois tasses de thé je note l'intention je la reconnais maintenant j'ai un choix j'ai le choix donc je peux attendre jusqu'à ce que cette énergie s'épuise progressivement mais en me connaissant
I will say yes.
Mais me connaissant, ce sera un oui.
Ah, so this, then something happens, an energy comes into the desire and manifests as an action.
Donc ce qui se passe, c'est que l'énergie pénètre à l'intérieur du désir et ensuite il y a l'action.
This is the will.
Will is energy.
La volonté, c'est l'action, c'est de l'énergie.
And energy produces action.
et l'énergie produit l'action donc le Bouddha est très clair là-dessus il dit la volonté c'est le karma donc ici karma veut dire l'acte donc c'est pas la même chose que ce qu'on emploie habituellement en parlant de karma comme c'est ton destin
C'est ce que tu mérites.
Donc, souvent, quand il y a deux choix, il y a confusion.
Et souvent, c'est le cas entre
Est-ce que je veux ou est-ce que je ne veux pas ?
Non, plutôt est-ce que je vais ou est-ce que je ne vais pas ?
Il se peut que vous ne pouvez simplement pas prendre la décision simplement parce qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment d'informations.
Mais ça peut aussi être un habit
de ne pas pouvoir prendre de décision et cela devient ce qu'on appelle le doute sceptique et cela veut dire que vous êtes tout le temps en train de vous saper avec le doute donc vous ne vous commettez jamais
Ça veut dire que vous ne vous engagez jamais.
Donc même si tout pointe en direction d'un choix, vous n'arrivez pas à faire ce pas.
et en restant avec le ressenti du doute sans se laisser prendre dans l'argumentation la longue liste pour et contre et vous restez à l'intérieur du doute
vous restez vraiment à l'intérieur du doute au début ça peut être un ressenti plutôt amorphe mais au moment où on pourrait dire ça commence à émerger du brouillard ça va manifester le vrai problème sur pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas commettre
Donc là, le vrai problème va commencer à se manifester sur la raison pour laquelle on n'arrive pas à s'engager.
Et donc, je pense que de manière incontournable, il devrait y avoir une sorte de peur.
Donc ça devient clair au moment où la personne doit faire une décision.
Et donc ce qui se passe souvent c'est que quand elle doit prendre la décision et bien tout à coup elle a vraiment très peur de prendre la décision.
d'avoir pris la mauvaise décision même si elle a pris la décision elle a peur, elle continue d'avoir peur d'avoir pris la mauvaise décision donc c'est comme tout état mental il faut le laisser se manifester et
quelque part il faut vous forcer à prendre une décision de manière à ne pas être contrôlé par la peur je pense que ce processus devient plus facile si vous ne voyez pas la vie comme soit un succès ou un échec c'est plus
trial and error.
Donc c'est plus un essai ou une erreur.
Essai et on verra.
That's an expression.
On n'apprendra pas ses erreurs, mais c'est plutôt... Try and we'll see.
Try and we'll see.
C'est une expression idiomatique.
Voilà.
Donc ça n'a rien à voir avec la paresse.
Donc ça pourrait conduire à la paresse parce que je ne peux pas prendre des décisions alors autant me rendormir.
Il dit, « Pouvez-vous expliquer la laziness ?
» Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Attends, la fainéantise, donc la laziness.
Oui, la fainéantise.
Qu'est-ce qui a de différent avec l'acceptance ?
Je ne comprends pas.
Est-ce que la question peut faire ça clair ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est la laziness, comme laisser aller.
Ah, oui, d'accord.
Oui.
Pour la question ?
La question est, qu'est-ce que la laziness ?
Et de quelle manière est-elle distincte de la laisser aller ?
D'accord, alors qu'est-ce que c'est la paresse et en quelle mesure est-ce qu'elle est différente du lâcher-prise ?
Ou de simplement accepter les choses.
Oui.
Eh bien, je pense que la laziness a plus à voir avec une attitude, c'est-à-dire ne pas se débrouiller.
Donc la paresse est plutôt liée à une attitude, au fait de ne pas se préoccuper de quelque chose.
Ça c'est une manifestation de l'ennui.
De la paresse.
Et ce boulot de laisser passer, c'est une décision active de laisser passer quelque chose.
Donc, l'histoire du lâcher-prise, c'est plutôt une décision active de laisser passer.
Donc, par exemple, supposons que quelqu'un arrive dans un problème où il doit y avoir des actions légales.
Donc, par exemple, on a une personne qui se trouve dans une situation où elle doit prendre une action légale.
Oui.
Par exemple, si une personne ressent très fortement quelque chose qui se passe dans son prochain voisin,
Donc, par exemple, une personne qui ressent quelque chose de très fort de ce qui s'est passé chez un voisin.
Par exemple, votre voisin a un chien vraiment vicieux.
Et vous voulez le rapporter, ce qui signifie que la police est impliquée, etc.
Donc vous voulez porter plainte pour inclure la police, pour impliquer la police.
Donc maintenant vous avez des problèmes avec le fait que cette personne peut vous causer des ennuis, de la violence.
Et quand vous avez éloigné les pros et les cons,
Et quand vous faites le pour et le contre, vous vous rendez compte que peut-être ça ne vaut pas la peine d'entreprendre cette action.
Donc ça, ce serait différent que de ne pas s'en préoccuper, ne pas...
C'est pas un exemple super malheureusement.
Mais j'espère que vous cernez l'idée.
Chaque année ou chaque deux années, j'ai un nouveau directeur qui vient m'aider au centre.
Chaque année ou chaque deux ans, il y a un nouveau manager qui vient m'aider au centre.
Il y a une certaine manière de faire les choses.
Le nouveau manager fait les choses un petit peu différemment.
Je vous donne un exemple.
Ce manager en particulier que j'ai, c'est très très bon.
donc ce manager que j'avais était vraiment très bon mais à chaque fois que quelque chose était renversé il utilisait du papier ménage pour l'essuyer de mon point de vue c'est une expérience inutile
pour moi c'est une dépense qui n'est pas nécessaire parce que nous avons une serviette pour essuyer la vaisselle
Deuxièmement, quand vous nettoyez avec du papier, il y a toujours quelque chose qui reste.
Vous voyez, ce n'est pas complètement hygiénique.
quand vous essuyez avec un morceau avec un papier ménage il reste toujours encore un petit peu de liquide donc ce n'est pas complètement propre et donc quand on est à la tête d'une institution publique on doit faire attention de ne pas empoisonner les personnes qui viennent donc je mentionne tout d'abord à lui
Donc la première chose que je fais, je le mentionne directement à lui.
Et à d'autres occasions, je le fais remarquer que ce n'est peut-être pas complètement hygiénique.
Et donc, la troisième tentative, je dis peut-être que ce n'est pas une dépense vraiment utile.
Et puis ensuite, je laisse tomber.
Donc, je pense que c'est essentiel d'apprendre à perdre une bataille pour pouvoir gagner la guerre.
Lorsque l'on prend conscience que l'on est stressé mais que l'on ne peut stopper l'action que l'on doit faire rapidement, par exemple au travail, suffit-il de rester en contact avec le corps à l'endroit où l'on ressent ce stress pour le faire baisser ?
Alors, quand on devient conscient qu'on est stressé, mais qu'on ne peut pas arrêter parce qu'on est au travail, par exemple, est-ce suffisant de rester en contact avec le corps, où on ressent le stress, pour le réduire ?
Oui, parce que, rappelez-vous, le stress est une réaction.
Donc oui, parce que, souvenez-vous que le stress c'est une réaction Donc personne n'est la cause de votre stress directement Donc une autre personne dans la même situation, il se peut qu'elle ne ressente pas de stress
Donc cela veut dire qu'il faut prendre entièrement toute la responsabilité sur le stress que l'on ressent.
Donc c'est ça la pleine conscience.
À partir du moment où vous ressentez cette mauvaise énergie, simplement détendez-vous.
Expirez.
Et puis commencez de nouveau.
Et puis recommencer.
Donc progressivement, vous pouvez lâcher ce sentiment, ce ressenti de stress.
Bon, même en disant, enfin à partir, il y a d'autres situations,
Où on est poussé.
Et ce que l'on attend de nous est en fait au-delà de nos capacités.
Donc si vous reconnaissez cela, alors à ce moment-là, c'est important de parler avec les personnes qui vous donnent le travail, de faire quelque chose.
Et si il n'y a aucune réponse à cela,
Et donc, s'il n'y a pas de solution à cette situation, alors le mieux c'est de partir.
Sinon, vous vous rendez malade.
De nos jours, tellement de personnes souffrent de ça.
Est-ce que vous pouvez en dire un peu plus sur l'équanimité et l'indifférence en ce qui concerne les actes de tous les jours ?
J'aime bien raconter une petite histoire à ce sujet.
Et quand j'étais en Thaïlande une fois, je suis allé rendre visite à un moine.
Et quand j'étais dans la pièce avec lui en train de parler, il y avait un chat qui jouait avec une souris.
La souris était déjà morte.
Maintenant, ce chat n'a pas besoin d'une souris.
Mais ce chat n'avait pas besoin d'une souris.
C'était un beau, gros chat.
Donc j'ai dit au moine, est-ce que tu ne l'as pas arrêté, arrêté le chat ?
C'est le karma du chat et le karma de la souris.
donc c'est intéressant parce que quelques semaines après cela donc j'étais assis sur un banc avec d'autres moines dans un jardin donc à l'intérieur d'un monastère et un chat a soudainement sauté sur un oiseau
Juste à ce moment-là, le même moine est allé vers le chat et lui a donné un coup de pied.
Et quand il a ramassé l'oiseau, l'oiseau était déjà mort.
Et il a dit, tu sais, il est mort.
Et puis il l'a tenu par les ailes pour regarder.
Aniccawata sankara.
chaque chose condamne tout conditionner apparaît et disparaît et il a très délicatement reposé l'oiseau sur la terre donc la différence ici
Le premier moine n'a pas vu que son attention de ce qui se passait était une partie de leur karma.
faisait partie du karma du chat et de la souris.
Il faisait partie de la situation.
Quand vous rentrez à la maison, vous pourrez voir un clip sur YouTube.
Et c'est à propos
En Chine, une petite fille de 2 ans a été renversée sur la route.
C'était dans toutes les nouvelles.
Et il y avait une de ces caméras.
Et je pense que c'était pendant 15 minutes.
Les gens se sont juste passés par.
pendant 15 minutes les gens ont passé à côté et n'ont rien fait et une autre voiture est arrivée et a passé par dessus la jambe et finalement une personne l'a ramassée et puis l'a mise de côté et elle est morte à l'hôpital
Donc, c'est une indifférence sévère.
Le gouvernement chinois a appelé pour les morales sociales.
Donc, c'est un cas très sévère, extrême.
Mais vous pouvez le voir, c'est une indifférence, c'est juste une calesse.
Donc vous pouvez voir, c'est vraiment une indifférence, une froideur.
Dans la même situation, quelle serait la réponse d'une personne qui agirait par l'équanimité ?
Donc, de manière instantanée, si cette personne voit cet enfant qui a été renversé, émerge directement ce désir d'aider.
Mais il reste toujours une calmeur.
Mais il resterait ce calme.
Bien sûr, la personne ramasserait l'enfant et ferait le nécessaire.
Maintenant, imaginez la réaction d'une mère qui verrait ça.
Donc il y aurait une panique immédiate, un désespoir immédiat.
Donc ce n'est pas la mesure de l'amour, c'est la mesure de l'attachement.
Maintenant, en disant cela, il faut être prudent de ne pas confondre l'attachement avec quelque chose d'immoral.
Donc il ne faut pas confondre maintenant l'attachement avec quelque chose d'immoral.
Donc ça ce n'est pas un meurtre ou bien un vol, c'est simplement une réaction humaine naturelle.
Donc une réaction naturelle d'une mère pour son enfant.
parce que cette panique, ce sens de détresse ne va pas aucunement aider l'enfant ça c'est la différence
Donc l'enfant peut être à nouveau en état de choc par la réaction de la mère.
Difficile, hein ?
C'est difficile.
Mais ce n'est pas mal.
C'est ce que j'essaie de dire.
L'attachement n'est pas la même catégorie que le mal.
Donc l'attachement n'est pas de la même sorte que ce qui est diabolique.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du végétarisme dans le bouddhisme ?
Il y en a certains qui mangent des animaux.
Est-ce qu'ils font cela parce que cela leur a été donné en cadeau ?
Oh, je vois, je vois.
Non, le Bouddha n'était pas concerné avec manger de la viande.
Le Bouddha, lui, n'était pas préoccupé par le fait de manger de la viande.
Il était plutôt préoccupé par la souffrance des animaux.
Donc, si un animal est tué ou meurt, vous pouvez le manger.
Je ne veux pas dire tué par un être humain, juste tué, comme ces morts de la route.
Donc c'est là où le problème se trouve pour les bouddhistes.
Donc c'est là qu'est le problème pour un bouddhiste.
Tout le monde mange de la viande.
C'est une obsession occidentale que les bouddhistes doivent être végétariens.
Le point est fait.
Si vous achetez de la viande, vous devez soutenir le végétarien.
Donc, bien sûr, il faut être clair sur le fait que si vous achetez de la viande, alors à ce moment-là, vous soutenez le boucher.
Alors, les Occidentaux, eux, peuvent accepter cela.
Par contre, les Orientaux ne peuvent pas.
Parce qu'ils disent que c'est la décision du boucher de tuer l'animal, pas celle-là.
Donc ils disent, c'est la décision du boucher de tuer l'animal, pas la mienne.
En d'autres termes, ils aiment trop leur viande.
Donc on était trois, quatre personnes avec mon maître au Bihara.
Et nous avons pointé cela à lui.
Donc on l'a fait remarquer cela.
Et il ne pouvait pas accepter l'argument.
Et on a continué, on a insisté.
Et finalement il a dit, peut-être.
Et puis ensuite nous sommes allés à Londres, peu après cela.
Et c'était très tôt le matin, donc nous avons allé manger dans un café local.
Donc c'était très tôt le matin, alors nous sommes allés prendre un petit déjeuner dans un café.
Donc j'ai commandé des œufs avec des beans, des haricots.
Et il a commandé du bacon.
Vous pouviez voir, il avait un petit peu honte.
Dans la société bouddhiste, le fait de tuer les animaux c'est vraiment les gens qui font partie de la catégorie la plus basse.
Donc c'est pour ça que lorsque les portugais sont arrivés au Sri Lanka, ils disaient que le Christ avait fait péché et il avait mangé de la viande.
Ils sont tous devenus catholiques.
le bord du Sri Lanka, les gens sont devenus catholiques parce qu'on leur a donné à nouveau leur dignité donc c'est le problème
Donc si vous êtes sensible à la souffrance animale, forcément vous ne voulez pas faire quelque chose qui va accroître cette souffrance.
Donc si vous allez dans un monastère en Orient, vous verrez qu'ils vont enfumer l'endroit contre les moustiques.
Et puis, en Sri Lanka, au nord, si votre chien ou votre chat a des moustiques ou des moustiques que vous ne voulez pas, vous les mettez dans le monastère.
Donc en Orient, si vous avez votre chat ou votre chien qui a des petits,
si vous ne les voulez pas vous les apportez simplement au monastère donc à Kanda Boda où je suis restée chaque mois vous aviez 20 à 25 chiens pendant 3 mois tous les 3 mois donc 20 à 25 chiens qui étaient apportés au monastère
et ensuite ce camion arrive et une viande spéciale était donnée aux chiens et ensuite ils emmenaient les corps les gens qui sont venus étaient chrétiens ou musulmans
donc les personnes qui venaient pour donner cette viande étaient soit des musulmans soit des chrétiens quelqu'un a fait passer le coup de téléphone donc c'est comme si vous aviez un problème supposons que vous avez une infestation de rat
Donc il y a un problème.
Supposez qu'il y a une invasion de rats.
Et donc pour des raisons sanitaires, vous allez devoir tuer les rats.
Donc c'est là qu'on constate que toutes ces lois morales, elles dépendent d'un contexte, d'une société donnée.
Donc il n'est pas possible d'avoir une loi absolue dans un univers relatif.
Si vous le faites, vous serez un extrémiste.
fondamentaliste les moines sont dans une position spéciale parce que les moines et les nonnes portent leur bol donc nous ne demandons rien
de particulier on espère simplement que quelqu'un va mettre de la nourriture dans le bol et donc si on nous met de la viande comme cela a été donné dans quelque sorte il faut le manger et il y a un exemple de cela dans les scriptures
Donc il y a un exemple dans les Écritures.
Un lépreux est venu mettre de la nourriture dans le bol d'un moine.
Et quand il a mis la nourriture, son pouce est tombé dedans.
Donc c'était une offrande.
Ce sont...
Voilà, donc ces petites histoires pour vraiment faire passer le message.
Mais par contre, si on sait qu'un animal a été tué spécialement pour nous, alors on ne peut pas l'accepter.
Donc si quelqu'un dit, j'ai juste tué ce poisson et je l'ai râché pour vous, vous devez dire non, merci.
Donc si quelqu'un vous dit, je viens de tuer cette poule et puis je l'ai cuite pour vous, alors là on doit dire non merci.
Je dois dire non.
C'est une règle.
Et aussi, comme tout le monde, je ne suis pas censé manger des léopards ou des éléphants.
Il y a une liste d'animaux que le Bouddha dit qu'on ne pouvait pas manger.
Seulement pour les moines et les nonnes, mais vous, vous pouvez manger.
Et souvenez-vous qu'au temps du Bouddha, il y avait une famine.
Donc c'est là qu'on doit tuer le stock d'êtres vivants.
Vous avez mentionné l'illusion existentielle dans le bouddhisme hier.
Pouvez-vous expliquer ?
Merci.
Vous avez mentionné l'illusion existentielle hier dans le bouddhisme.
Pouvez-vous expliquer ?
l'angoisse existentielle c'est ce que vous ressentez quand votre vie n'a pas de sens
Donc, je pense que le auteur le plus clair était Albert Camus.
Vous connaissez peut-être son livre, le mythe de Sisyphus.
Donc, le mythe de Sisyphus.
Le mythe de Sisyphus.
Je ne me souviens plus pourquoi il était puni.
Est-ce que quelqu'un sait ?
Il a fait quelque chose de vraiment très grave.
Donc il a été condamné à rouler une énorme boule tout en haut d'une colline.
Et quand il est arrivé au top, il a tourné tout le way down.
Et au moment où il arrivait au sommet, elle devait rouler de l'autre côté.
Donc il devait redescendre et puis la remonter.
Pour le reste des jours.
Pour toujours.
Et parfois la vie ressemble à ça.
On fait la même chose encore et encore.
donc dans le bouddhisme cette idée de revenir et puis de renaître, de réincarnation donc ça c'était vraiment une des
des horreurs, des choses les plus terribles pour l'époque donc si vous allez lire les philosophies de l'époque tout tourne autour de comment mettre fin à ce cycle donc il y avait une philosophie c'était le matérialisme pur et dur une fois que vous mourrez c'est fini
une autre c'était simplement vous allez progressivement vers des états mentaux plus élevés et puis vous mourrez
Après la mort physique, c'est l'anéantissement.
D'autres, bien sûr, étaient plus optimistes.
Donc on montait, on montait et puis on finissait au niveau du Brahma.
Ça c'était pour l'éternité.
Un peu comme les chrétiens et les musulmans qui parlent du paradis.
Donc une crise existentielle vient avec la question, mais pourquoi suis-je en vie ?
Donc ça c'est une des bénédictions d'un chemin spirituel.
Donc ça vous donne vraiment ce fondement de sens profond à la vie.
Donc le Bouddha dit qu'il y a un endroit qui n'appartient pas à ce monde phénoménal
Et elle a ces trois qualités, c'est un endroit permanent.
Il n'y a pas de souffrance.
Il faut faire attention avec le mot bonheur parce que pour nous c'est un état émotionnel.
Et même si c'est un état émotionnel, ce n'est pas le bonheur.
Donc même dans ce cas-là, il n'y a pas de soi.
Ce n'est pas un soi.
Donc le bonheur à partir du monde est basé sur des conditions.
Qui ne peut pas contrôler ?
lesquels ne peuvent pas être contrôlés donc lesquels ne peut-on pas contrôler donc le bonheur sur le fait de ne pas désirer, ne pas s'attacher est aussi basé sur une condition des conditions
c'est ça, c'est ça
Je peux le traduire parce que j'ai écrit le questionnement.
C'est la même chose.
Des bonheurs ou des joies qui viennent du monde, il y a des conditions qu'on n'a pas de contrôle.
Et des joies ou des bonheurs qui viennent du fait de non-saisie,
Il y a aussi une condition, et la condition c'est qu'on sait comment mettre en pratique le non-saisir, le lâcher prise.
Donc la question c'est, est-ce qu'il y a un bonheur qui est non-conditionné ?
Donc le bonheur de ne pas saisir...
n'est pas un état émotionnel donc c'est pour ça que le Bouddha préférait le terme non-souffrance donc cela veut dire que cette satipanya cette attention intuitive est capable d'apprécier les choses
est capable d'apprécier les choses qui sont conditionnées mais parce qu'elle ne les saisit pas donc elle reste toujours dans un état d'équilibre donc c'est ça le bonheur du non-attachement
Si vous êtes l'observateur à l'intérieur de vous-même, vous êtes celui qui ressent, celui qui expérimente.
Toutes ces choses apparaissent et passent, mais l'observateur ne bouge pas.
Et qu'est-ce que...
Dans quel est l'état de l'observateur ?
Donc il n'y a pas d'émotion là.
Non.
Dans l'idée de l'observateur.
Donc, quand vous êtes très clairement l'observeur, le ressenteur, le connaisseur, l'expérienceur, juste vous demandez à vous-même, qu'est-ce que c'est comme d'être là ?
C'est ce à quoi nous nous pointons, c'est ce qui pointe vers la bonheur du non-clingé.
donc cela vous emmène vers ce bonheur qui est sans attachement c'est comme lorsque vous avez une maladie et puis la maladie s'en va donc quand la maladie s'en va vous avez la joie de ne pas être en maladie
Quand la maladie est loin, vous avez le bonheur de ne plus avoir de la maladie.
C'est un bonheur en négatif.
donc il n'y a rien dans ce monde qui ne paraît la peine que l'on s'y attache cela paraît extrême est-ce que c'est vraiment possible pour un être humain de ne pas s'attacher à son nouveau-né par exemple c'est aussi l'inverse dans les histoires du Bouddha dans les vieilles histoires
donc ça semble aussi être l'opposé des histoires qui racontent les vies passées du Bouddha quand il a sacrifié sa vie pour un autre être et aussi l'histoire du Dalai Lama en ressentant que l'un de ses bons amis est mort
qui est triste après avoir appris la nouvelle du décès d'un ami proche donc il n'y a rien dans ce monde qui ne vaille la peine que l'on s'y attache donc fait référence à l'acte de saisir c'est la qualité de l'attachement
Donc elle fait référence à cette qualité d'attachement.
Mais cela n'empêche pas l'amour, la compassion et la joie.
Parce que l'amour vrai et la compassion vraie
Et puis la joie réelle n'est pas teintée de cette « mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a pour moi ?
» Parce que l'attachement c'est « mais alors, qu'est-ce qu'il y a pour moi ?
»
si un être pleinement éveillé avait un nouveau-né si une mère pleinement éveillée avait un bébé elle serait vraiment très heureuse la joie si malheureusement ce bébé venait à mourir le jour suivant elle serait capable de le laisser partir
Elles devraient être capables juste de laisser aller.
Parce qu'il n'y a pas d'attachement.
Donc une fois on a demandé au Bouddha, comment est-ce que vous vous sentez quand les gens n'arrivent pas à accepter votre doctrine ?
il dit qu'il est équanime, qu'il est ok avec cela comment il se sent quand quelqu'un reçoit ses enseignements ?
je me sens heureux je me sens heureux oui, il est content c'est cette confusion habituelle entre ce que nous voulons par amour et attachement
donc c'est toujours cette confusion qui vient de cet amour attachement qu'on peut ressentir et puis cet amour compassion qui est
vraiment être là pour l'autre, pour le bien-être de l'autre.
Donc, ce qui concerne la tristesse du Dalai Lama pour son ami.
Donc, si c'est un chagrin, alors à ce moment-là, le Dalai Lama exprime un attachement.
Donc je ne crois pas qu'il ait dit nulle part qu'il était complètement libéré.
Mais d'un autre côté, il y a aussi ce qu'on appelle la tristesse.
Sorrow is the feeling you get when you see somebody else suffering.
Donc cette tristesse vient quand on voit la souffrance chez quelqu'un d'autre et c'est ce qui nous motive à vouloir les aider.
Vous connaissez la troisième symphonie de ce compositeur polonais ?
C'est la musique de l'Holocauste.
Moi, quand j'écoute cette musique, c'est très douloureux.
J'ai aussi vu un interview à ce sujet.
Et c'est vraiment une tristesse vraiment très pure.
Donc, normalement, la tristesse vous amène à la dépression.
Elle vous empêchera.
elle vous ôte votre pouvoir.
Tandis que la tristesse, c'est quoi la différence entre sorrow et la tristesse ?
Donc c'est plutôt tristesse, chagrin, peine, peut-être peine.
Donc cette peine, elle vous conduit à faire quelque chose, à agir.
je peux seulement espérer que mes paroles ont pu vous être utiles que je n'ai pas créé de confusion que ça vous excite à plus d'efforts
Et que cela va vous motiver pour plus d'efforts.
Et qu'avec tous ces efforts, vous serez libérés de la souffrance.
Tôt plutôt que tard.